hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba John is
me you know it's hot right now
sean.conner and love them everyone's
been going we need shock contact we had
Billy where's the you would have fixed
crystal skull we're still thinking about
that are we man why didn't he make a
cameo and Daniel Craig's last Bond
movies where is Sean Connery where is
the sequel to Sartre Oz you know who
wants Sean Connery back is a man named
Mikhail Linden over at our patreon what
of our top reward tiers whatever video
you requested must definitely do
currently booked up or wore tear so
Mikhail you just made the cut buddy top
10 Sean Connery performances from
watchmojo.com I'm excited to check this
out because I'm a huge connor fun you're
you're a fun car honest Kanaan our
summer rockin honor songs some of their
older videos so it's probably less to be
impression welcome to watchmojo.com and
today we're finally at Forest Whitaker
the rock League of Extraordinary
Gentlemen
I heard he hated working with Michael -
number ten
Robert Mack with Dougal and Travis
that's Matt Connery gets the chance to
play the ladies man some 30 years after
its heyday as a sex symbol he proves
he's as witty as ever when he and
Catherine zeta-jones attempt to pull off
an art heist for eight billion dollars
yes hot stuff we are downloading we have
to download a I'm clear on whether she's
truly working against him or with him
but half the fun is watching the sparks
fly oh that's when they made this famous
going through the lasers hip link story
economy character British sergeant
Daniel Dravot seeks fortune in
comparison at a land outside the reach
of the British Empire
he and his fellow soldier portrayed by
Michael Caine convinced the natives that
he's a god a far-fetched lie is made
believable by the ease of the two men's
on-screen and real-life friendship but
between that and the camera we're on the
edge of our seats to see if their secret
will be discovered
[Music]
Rising Sun 800 time throughout his
career economy has always taking chances
on roles
this one is no student while critics
gave it a mixed reviews fans loved
watching Connor investigating the murder
of a prostitute it's exhilarating to see
how he pieces together the clues from
the murder scene
and uses knowledge of Japanese affairs
as a way to pinpoint the killer Arthur
first night the best modern-day haircut
oh this is when freakin Richard Gere was
Lancelot yeah
my highlighter awesome is this wasn't to
trace Ramirez as light as an immortal
and we see how he eventually becomes a
mentor to the Highlander you must learn
to power until the time of the gathering
decide by flitterjahr the economies out
of rules who's that fella goes to show
he's got ranged how he fights it you
think the actors
number five John Patrick Mason the rock
let's find out how he seems to be yes I
was just thinking a pseudo reincarnation
of his James Bond character
this movie is less refined than its
double-o seven days with boys it's fun
to see him kicking ass and packing heat
as he attempts a reverse prison break
[Music]
yeah bring her gone to a knife fight
no knife to a gunfight he won the Oscar
for this Jim Malone he's the tough but
maternal Irish American cop who assists
Eliot Ness in his pursuit of the
notorious shot such as such a department
shock died after thanks to his powerful
for Tripp Connolly was awarded his first
and only Oscar for Best Supporting Actor
and earned a career resurgence as well
oh is it number three yes
Indiana Jones and the Last Crusade
it's race against evil Indiana Jones is
an iconic character but it's crazy how
like great their chemistry is in this
burrito like it's so good in reality the
two men are only 12 years apart in age
but the chemistry between
[Music]
oh yeah this is our he plays a British
with a thick Scottish accent places
Spanier with you plays oh no that was
John Wayne was Genghis Khan never mind I
know Mom I know my Connery
yeah but I'm gonna get the next
honorable mention wrong please say
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen
something we've gone through his whole
filmography practically
yep
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] I [ __ ] it up I had do you agree
with our list what's your favorite Sean
Connery performance
four more exception our top ten is
public deal if you sure to subscribe to
watchmojo.com it's good but it's good
lesson man some good some good shot car
expected probably a lot of deep cuts I
don't really know do I
and the most iconic Connery's are
probably the ones that you've heard a
lot about I remember a few these from
like my youth and they stood out so
prominently that yeah I recognized more
than I thought I would do he is someone
who does get better with age I'll I'll
never forget whatever Wesley Snipes
popped up for Rising Sun I remember
there was some interview when it Connor
had Late Night with Conan O'Brien and he
was talking about how Sean Connery told
him that whenever he did the driving
scenes as like double-oh-seven or even
some car scenes and Rising Sun he would
just take off his pants because it would
get so hot so ever I watch like he's
doing a chase scene with the
green-screen I'm on Bond movies good
what's the roads pants-off must be sure
tails and garters right where my mind
goes you must you must not have any
pants on right now right I'm just gonna
assume that if I ever see a scene in
which Sean Connery is driving there are
no business well I think severed movie
put I don't know if Sean Connery would
be working in these times something that
I've heard a lot of women actually tell
me is that there's an interview where
Sean Connery said that I forget the
exact context sure I'm you know Google
search away before everyone gets mad at
me he thinks it's okay to murder a woman
yeah is what he said right
he said we should a man a woman and we
don't give birth murder murder no it's
something about like problematic favi
problematic faith yeah I don't think he
would feel like if he had a Twitter he'd
be getting tweeted at a lot I don't
think he's gonna come out of retirement
yeah one already played sexist
womanizing manipulator bond so well yeah
where else is there left to go
the hardest time watching his old Bond
films cuz I'm like this guy's such a
dbag Oh classic Bond is a not your kind
of guy nah I like she does everything
right except when he's interacting with
women I'm not trying to sound like mr.
progressive or anything like that it's
just as Who I am today when I watch that
I go this is wrong and though I
understand that this is a time capsule
kind of the same guy just dial it down a
little bit more and then when they bring
it back inspector you're like oh god
it's weird
entrapment though man it's true like he
is someone as he gets older he gets more
badass he started on the League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen which I think I
think was his last live-action
performance even that movie which was
not a good film but even in that you're
like you don't question it go it's not
like when you cast anybody else who's
old for these movies pretty good aren't
they kind of old to do that you don't
even think it like art yeah I are too
old man badass like yeah like so many of
us I think grew up with a contemporary
Connery that was already older so yeah
it's like he's a staple of my my life in
that way and yeah I hadn't really
thought of it but I just associate him
with being a badass even when he plays
old people he's always so good I forget
what interview I heard him in a long
time ago I think women it was a slapping
woman interview which was a very
inspiring interview outside of that one
Parker it was when you just saying like
you know I just have a job to do I go in
there I do my job you feel that level of
just conviction in a professional
showing up on set ray do his thing why I
heard is that he didn't like working
with Michael Bay of the way he does his
camera work and everything like that
it's not really about performances it's
just like the cameras always freaking
moving and stuff and you got to imagine
when you have an actor of the caliber of
talent of Sean Connery who likes to
perform then you got this like hyper
style because he's so good in the rock
yeah yeah when I hear that John Carter
doesn't like were you a Michael Bay
because of his directing style maybe
that tension helped you know yeah
formants and whatnot he's got that
uncanny ability kind of like Arnold
except you know obviously better actor
where it didn't matter if he had a
Scottish accent yes believed it anyway
you know I've seen Highlander countless
times never like what's up with his
voice he's come from spray yeah yeah but
in the Hunt for Red October they
establish it well because they're all
speaking Russian and then they do this
like pan and shot on his mouth they show
that okay but when we're with them we're
gonna hear them in English you're not
watching a bunch of subtitles so we
didn't have to teach Sean Connery
Russian feel like that movie accounts
for it pretty weirdly I saw The Hunt for
Red October like a bunch of times as a
child one of my mom's favorite movies he
was a boring to me growing up I know
submarine yeah and I feel like as a kid
I was like this should be thrilling
they're in a submarine yeah yeah that'd
be curious to revisit it now the rock
and entrapment often blur together in my
mind there's no really good reason for
that other than they came out of a
certain specific nebulous blob of time
and I think I saw both on airplanes
really I saw the rock twice in the
theaters really yeah they're freaking
awesome movie I can say you know I think
my favorite one is him as Indies father
oh yeah I gotta say like it's
fascinating to me to is that arguably
out of all these choices it's like you
expect that movie to be on this list and
of all these choices that's the least
tough one yeah you know yeah like Indies
the tough one you know shoots people
he's like oh yeah
he's like watching a mess looks totally
he does is with the birds of the
umbrella or something yeah yeah yeah he
gets turned and everything like father
tough he stands up whatever but like
Indy's the tough action hero and he's
not mm-hm
but somehow their chemistry is beautiful
that movie called the dog Indiana
untouchables is my probably my second
favorite performance of his he is
amazing in that typical day go I'm
Italian I can say it I'm part Italian
too
you're not Italian enough uh yeah I know
you're the gatekeeper cuz you're the
more Italian you gotta you gotta be like
a big mmm you know this would be a big
part of your life as I recall you're not
as Italian as you thought you were I'll
have you know mr. Kaiba I grew up with
Italians my Graham I came from Italy
doesn't matter all right just stop say
the N word John hey McHale I thought I
was gonna be looking at a list wrong
like what is this for a majority but
both of those movies he was a legend he
was a legend
he is a legend yes he's still around see
it's a good thing he disappeared before
the movements yeah before all this had
time to resurface on the internet if he
said that I gotta at least imagine that
he's hit several with which is not funny
why are we laughing about this well you
cuz you imagine an alternate reality now
we're like Sean Connery is the Cosby of
our time
what what yeah all right well let's end
it there I've actually never seen that
interview and it's worse than I actually
thought god that's pretty awful that's
pretty bad oh man just makes you kinda
question well that's I think if he was
still in the spotlight this would be
everywhere would at least be some kind
of domestic violence claim it's very
least like I don't know if he would have
sexually assault anybody given the
movements that we're dealing it's yeah
it's all nasty we got a whole bunch of
goodies
thanks for kale Oh McHale Gail Linden
around christmastime McCarroll increases
his pledge does he wanted us to react to
this video I want to say thank you
buddies are awesome hunky dunky man from
Sweden he's rich ladies if all the
Swedish female fan base
watching his rich so jump on and he was
saying that and he said Merry Christmas
oh they said he's Sweden he sent us an
audio of how to say it and here it's
felt G OTT space nytt space a with a ho
above it I forget what that thing's
called a bubble R and you pronounce it
got me a gun it Oh God snake or nope got
the a are we sure I like had it and then
we started doing this and I was like I'm
pretty sure I'm right okay just like
Sean Connery is in that Barbara I'm
trying to jump on the bandwagon with the
movement of comedians you know protested
oh yeah how many should be a license to
say anything you want with no
repercussions yeah you're not allowed to
respond to comedian